-Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Enjoy yourself.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show,"
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Applause ]
Thank you for being here.
Guys, it seems like there's
so much going on right now.
Former President Trump is
being sued by
New York's attorney general
for fraud.
The United Nations General
Assembly is underway.
This weekend, Disney is
re-releasing the movie "Avatar."
[ Laughter ]
In theaters.
They're re-releasing it.
And the FTA is warning people
against following
a TikTok recipe for
Nyquil chicken.
There's just so much to go over,
so let's just jump in
and cover it all at once.
It's time for a "News Smash."
♪♪
First up, Trump.
The attorney general of New York
is suing him
for allegedly lying about
the value of his assets.
Between this,
the January 6th committee,
and the stolen
classified documents,
Trump's got more problems
to deal with than...
the United Nations.
Their big General Assembly
is this week in New York City,
and every hotel, restaurant,
and street is absolutely packed.
But you know what isn't packed?
A movie theater showing
"Avatar."
[ Laughter ]
That movie came out in 2009,
and now it's being re-released.
Nobody really asked for it,
but here it is.
Kind of like...
Nyquil chicken.
People saw the recipe on TikTok,
and now the FTA is saying,
stay away.
It sounds gross, but if you fry
it and throw it in a bucket,
it's perfect for...
Donald Trump.
[ Laughter ]
This latest lawsuit...
[ Applause ]
He's in serious legal trouble,
but honestly,
by now, it kind of
feels like we've...
seen this movie before.
If you forgot, "Avatar" is about
oddly colored creatures
that have fallen on hard times,
which sounds a lot like...
Donny T.
[ Laughter ]
When Trump was interviewed
by state officials,
he pleaded the fifth,
because when it came to
answering questions,
he was too...
chicken.
Come on, guys!
Don't make Nyquil chicken
or Tamiflu turkey
or Robitussin ribs.
That stuff will make you turn...
blue.
Back in '09,
"Avatar" made over $2 billion,
which is also how much...
Trump said
his apartment's worth.
And if you think that's legal,
you must be high on...
sizzurp chicken.
So in conclusion...
nations unite...
losing fight.
Back in blues...
chicken snooze.
This has been a "News Smash."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, this is fun.
Earlier tonight,
Elton John performed
on the South Lawn
of the White House.
It was an exciting night
for the Bidens.
The concert started right
after dinner, at 3:00 PM.
[ Laughter ]
Biden hosting Elton John at
the White House makes sense.
There's no better anthem for
a 79-year-old president
than a song called
"I'm Still Standing."
Don't you think?
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I saw that it's
National Dog Week, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And to celebrate, Tinder is
putting rescue dogs on their app
to match them
with potential owners.
It's exactly the same
as normal Tinder.
Everyone says they enjoy food
and long walks on the beach.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a popular
craft beer in Australia
was recalled over concerns
of "excess alcohol."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, the people who
bought it were like,
"We can't recall anything."
We have a great show, you guys!